le maternage je suis arrêté par des
hommes cagoulés qui m'arrêtent de
manière très violente sous les yeux de
ma fille ces petits déjeuners et je
comprends pas je suis menotté on me met
une cagoule noire sur la tête je
maintenant qui sont ces hommes et si on
si on n'est pas dans une scène
d'exécution la première chose que
j'essaie de faire c'est d'essayer de
comprendre qu'ils sont ils que volatile
rapidement je vais comprendre que son ce
sont des agents du fsb donc lé
successeur du kgb
[Musique]
on
dans un premier temps je suis accusé de
diffusion de documents
pédopornographiques et rapidement je
vais être accusé du viol de ma propre
fille c'est une accusation montée de
toutes pièces
on a trafiqué mon ordinateur on l'a
utilisé pour publier des images
criminelle et ensuite sur cette base là
on a inventé cette accusation de viol
sur ma propre fille je sais que ce que
je suis en train de vivre ses 1 comprend
matt compromettent ça veut dire dossiers
compromettants quelqu'un essaye de
m'éliminer en utilisant contre -1
dossiers compromettants
je suis jeté en prison et l'a donc je
vais vivre 71 jours en prison
le plus dur c'est de vivre à 10 dans 25
30 mètres carrés dans des conditions
sanitaires difficiles à la puanteur et
là les toilettes sont à côté
et puis surtout de survivre au milieu de
bandits de mafieux de criminels de haut
vol pour certains
sachant que j'ai gravées sur mon front
l'article 130 de l'article des violeurs
l'article qui dis que j'ai peut-être
violé mineurs en prison
les violences elles peuvent venir des
codétenus mais surtout et avant tout des
gardiens dont j'ai connu cette violence
là en particulier
le 14 février jour de la saint-valentin
ce sont des gardiennes qui s'amusent qui
rigole qui boivent et qui font sortir
les détenus les uns après les autres
un par un et moi un moment je suis donc
extrait de la cellule et
on ma tâche les mains à des barreaux et
on me frappe au niveau des testicules
le but c'est que les détenus soient
obéissant c'est de l'intimidation du
dressage et puis c'est pour casser en
fait pour casser systématiquement la
volonté je passe par des grands moments
d'abattement je peux tomber dans
l'alcool à certains moments et puis je
me reprends enfin je me dis il faut
sortir de cette situation il faut
m'évader j'utilise pour ça un papier
aluminium je retouche recouvre mon
bracelet électronique de papier
aluminium s'accouplent signale
immédiatement normalement quelqu'un doit
réagir et venir m'arrêter ou voir où je
suis et je constate que le dimanche
lorsque je place du papier aluminium
autour de mon bracelet
personne ne vient ça déclenche aucune
réaction pendant au moins quatre ou cinq
heures donc si je m'évade un dimanche je
peux avoir quatre ou cinq heures
d'avancé sur mu poursuivre
les diplomates craignent évidemment un
incident diplomatique
donc il entre en discussion avec avec
les russes et le le risque c'est ça et
le risque pour moi à terme c'est que ma
situation devienne publique et les
russes ont averti le jour où
publiquement on révèle que yoann
barberot et au sein de l'ambassade
alors nous ferons le siège de
l'ambassade et jamais il ne sortira je
décide de sortir de l'ambassade donc de
déjouer les systèmes de sécurité de
l'ambassade de sortir et de traverser la
frontière pour ça je me suis préparé
j'ai étudié les cartes satellites
pendant des mois j'ai repéré un point où
je peux passer en estonie je vais sortir
et là une amie russe va m'aider ce que
j'ai pas dit c'est que dans chacune de
mes fuite
les véritables héros ce sont mes amis
russes eux ils ont pris des risques pour
pour aider au nom de l'amitié et la
fraternité
est-ce que vous avez été un agent
français ou es ce que vous avez été
proche des services pour que les
autorités russes vous en veille autant
non non j'ai alors il est possible que
les autres non mais attendez si vous
étiez un agent vous verriez non quand
même oui voilà donc vous voyez donc la
question est impossible
ce que craignait le plus les hommes que
j'avais sur le dos le fsb c'est que tout
finisse dans un livre ce livre j'ai fini
par l'écrire j'ai commencé à l'écrire en
prison j'ai inscrit sur mes petits
cahiers verts dans les geôles de sibérie
et c'est le titre de ce livre il aurait
dédié dans le livre les passages où je
m'enfuis je les ai je les écris à la
troisième personne je suis sortie hors
de moi je suis peu moi même en fait je
suis un personnage du roman que je suis
en train d'écrire je l' ai vécu comme ça
et c'est ça qui m'a aidé et je crois à
faire le plus dur ce que j'ai écrit dans
le livre est absolument vrai mon parti
pris c'est je n'invente rien je ne
recommence jamais en revanche se prendre
pour un personnage de fiction au moment
où on est en train de vivre des
expériences traumatisantes et difficile
ça peut être une aide
ça peut être une force